[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره
اعلنت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان الرياض
والطيران اتفقتاه على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح السفارتين في غضون
شهرين وذكرت الوكاله ان التوصل الى هذا
الاتفاق جاء عقب مباحثات جرت في الصين مع
الرئيس الصيني
واضافتنا المباحثات جاءت رغبه من طهران
والرياض في حل الخلافات بالحوار
والدبلوماسيه ونقلت الوكاله السعوديه عن
بيان سعودي صيني ايراني ان وزيري خارجيه
البلدين سيجتمعان لترتيب تبادل السفراء
ومناقشه سبل تعزيز العلاقات وقال الكبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين ان محادثات
السعوديه وايران نصر للسلامه بدوره قال
البيت الابيض انه ليس واضحا ما اذا كان
الاتفاق سيؤثر على اتفاقيه ابرهام
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ان استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين بلاده وايران ياتي
انطلاقا من رؤيه المملكه القائمه على
تفضيل الحلول السياسيه والحوارات واضاف ان
دول المنطقه يجمعها مصير واحد وقواسم
مشتركه تجعل من الضروره ان تتشارك سويا
لبناء نموذج للازدهار والاستقرار بحسب
تعبيره
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امين عبد اللهيان ان سياسه حسن الجوار
التي تنتهجها حكومه بلاده تسير في الاتجاه
الصحيح بدوره قال امين مجلس الامن القومي
الايراني ان طهران اتفقت مع الرياض على
فتح صفحه جديده بناء على مصالح البلدين
والامن الاقليمي
نقلت وكاله تسنيم عنا ممثل ايران في الامم
المتحده ان طيران ابرمت اتفاقيه مع روسيا
لتزويدها بطائرات سخوي 35 وكانت شبكه
سينان الامريكيه نقلت عن مصادر وصفتها
بالمطالعه ان روسيا ارسلت لايران بعض
الاسلحه والمعدات التي قدمتها واشنطن
والنيتو الى اوكرانيا واستولت عليها موسكو
واضافت ان من بين هذه المنظومات صواريخ
جافلين المضاده للدبابات وصواريخ ستينجر
المضاده للطائرات
اعلنت ميليشيا فاجن الروسيه تعزيز مواقعها
في المناطق الشرقيه بمدينه باخموت شرقيه
اوكرانيا اقضت انها تخوض معارك ضاريا مع
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك وقال المتحدث باسم
القوات الاوكرانيه في الشرق ان القوات
الروسيه تواصل محاوله شن هجمات باتجاه او
باتجاه وسط بخموت مؤكدا ان قوته تواصل
الدفاع عن مواقعها
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض
ان روسيا تحاول اثاره تمرد داخل جمهوريه
مولدوفال محاذيه لكل من اوكرانيا ورومانيا
من جهته وصف وزير الخارجيه الروسيه اي عمل
المحتمل ضد قوات بلاده المتمركزه في
مولدوفا بانها اعتداء مباشره على بلاده
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]